we were gonna talk I was gonna talk
about this a few weeks ago okay so um
when I moved to San Francisco I started
a book club called the anti MBA and I
did it because I didn't go to an elite
Ivy League school but I was always
envious of those people because when I
moved here I didn't know a single soul
and I felt I always like stereotypes
people is like tall beautiful white
teeth with Patagonia's and they had like
lovely networks that you saw all around
ya just like these like rich white
people who that's how I was like right
that's how I imagined it and it kind of
was that and I was always envious of
that so what I did was I create a book
club meeting where we would meet every
week and we would read one book a month
and I would convince an expert how did
you convince people to join this where'd
you throw it up a cold email guy I just
learned how to cold email people and I I
did it online so each week we would have
30 people show up and I probably had an
email list of 5000 people who would I
was not in person this is all online 30
people in person see Ava yeah a lot of
my best friends I met this way 30 people
my friend had an office and he let me
use it and we would just meet up and I
would and I would read a week ahead of
time and just make notes and lead
discussion and sometimes we would have
an expert okay and then I would send
show notes or meeting notes to the list
and people loved it I made close to no
money off of it or I don't think I made
any money off it I just did it for fun
and it was very success successful and a
lot of people said that we should make
it a thing I think it's a stupid I
thought it was a stupid idea but what
clubs are actually kind of interesting
so there's this business called
book-of-the-month Club it was started
and I believe it was started in the
1930s at this point it's owned by it was
owned by Bertelsmann which is a large
publisher of multi billion-dollar
publisher and then recently a private
individual bought it for single-digit
millions of dollars in in the 40s 50s
and 60s this was massive I mean it was
millions of people paid for so it was
quite a large business hundreds of
millions of dollars probably in the 60s
and 70s it's gone away once Amazon came
around a guy bought it a couple years
ago
it's quite large still and what they do
is score down a little bit this is 90
million users what the hell no that's
Goodreads oh that's good range and so
look at the Month Club now has a hundred
thousand active paying customers Wow
which means they're in the revenue range
of ten to fifteen million a year in
recurring revenue and they the founder
said in an interview he want his goal is
to grow 5x a year for the next year not
consistently I don't know if that's I
think that's bogus
but Book of the Month is kind of an
interesting thing I suspect I've always
thought that it would would not work now
my opinion has changed so Goodreads has
a hundred million users there's this
thing called Wattpad have you heard of
Wattpad I've heard of it yeah what Pat a
lot of people don't know about it
Wattpad it's owned by a guy in Canada
and they have 400 employees it's a
multiple hundred million dollar a year
business I believe they it's a book club
for it's not a book club it's more write
on it you you write original stories
yeah but it's the categories roman
middle middle america romance novels so
if you're a 40 year old woman you
probably have heard a lot pat you're
saying that's the most popular category
or yeah buddy much all they do oh really
okay it's basically for women who it's
like men do video porn romance novels is
woman porn basically and so huge
business and now I'm quite bullish now
on these book clubs yeah Reese
Witherspoon has a book club my wife uses
it my sister used so many people have
you heard of this no sunshine some
thing
Oprah had hers but hers wasn't on paid
membership
but this is really smart like what
you're describing I'm like oh this is
good I think you gotta have probably not
gotta have but it's advantageous here to
have a brand like a Reese Witherspoon or
whoever Jennifer Aniston or Gwyneth
Paltrow or whoever or like the hustle
could do a book club you could do a book
club like I think that you have to have
a bit of cachet to organize people
around to get the energy going that
initial energy so here's one angle you
buy the rights to the book which is
expensive yeah why would you do that
well because I think the margins and
books are quite small I've talked to Tim
Ferriss about this he told me that he
earns
I he didn't say that he didn't tell me
this but he told me I mean I think that
he does about a million a month in
revenue off his podcast and he told me
that he this what he did tell me he has
made 10 times more money off the podcast
and all of his books combined right so I
I don't think people get paid a lot of
money for books March it might be a
cheap asset you're saying yeah I think
it's quite cheap so I would one-up my
goal would be to buy the rights to the
book and make it popular you know who
have you heard of um there's this
company that owns the company that owns
Proactiv it's called God I know what
you're talking about it's a skincare
it's a direct marketing company they the
guy who owns it it's a quite large
business he got his start because he
bought the rights to think & Grow Rich
oh really and he helped to make it
popular again oh wow through
infomercials so that's what I would do
is I would want to buy the rights to all
the books and there's another company
called Mentor box that does this and tie
loop has is one of the owners so it's
incredibly scamming I mean like you sign
up for like $20 and then it rolls into
like a $400 a month thing it's like
stupid but book clubs are super
interesting to me
so would you do this like if you were
gonna do this now how would you attack
it what would you do so you buy the
right so that you buy the right if I
wanted to bootstrap it no you can't how
would you do it so what I would do is I
would look at what you've I know me
please vinyl me please is my friends
business it's a probably a couple
million bucks a month subscription
things so what you do is you give them
$50 a month
and they send you a vinyl once a month
right and so I would do that but for a
particular type of category so what I
would do is how to create a Facebook
group and I would say it's $30 or $50 a
month and we're gonna read one book a
month I'm gonna get one expert to come
and talk about the book each week or
each month we're gonna do in a Facebook
group and I'm gonna send you notes about
the whole and what category do you think
you choose would you do the romance
novel or would you do business or would
you do well just because I have such a
networking business that I could just
crush it up the baddest yeah but romance
novels I know this from experience cuz
I've invested in these types of things
romance novels have them have the
highest liquidity PS and people consume
them the most right
so I like voracious readers five five
times the number of bromance category is
probably one of the most
it's probably the most popular category
on Kindle yeah I bet you it is so okay I
personally I would start here but if I
even slightly was interested in romance
novels I would and I like what this guy
did buying the rights to the Book of the
Month Club further you know some a
popular asset that's sort of decayed
over the last thirty years and see if
you can revitalize it on the cheap
there's interesting businesses there's
so many books that I love that are
written in the 60s and 70s and you try
to buy them on Amazon and they're
hundreds of dollars because they've just
been forgotten and they don't reprint
them right I just try to buy a book the
other day for that someone mentioned it
on Twitter and it was $900 book it was
so I just tweeted about Agora that's the
scammy
company which we can talk about if we
want but the it was all about
copywriting was 900 bucks
[Music]
you